>> Jason: WELCOME BACK TO THIS
SPECIAL EDITION OF HANNITY.
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI'S HYPOCRISY
IS ON FULL DISPLAY ONCE AGAIN AS
SHE CONTINUES TO ENFORCE THE
MASK MANDATE IN THE HOUSE EVEN
THOUGH THERE'S NOT ONE IN THE
SENATE OR AT THE WHITE HOUSE, HE
OR SHE IS AT A WHITE HOUSE EVENT
YESTERDAY WHERE SHE WAS SEEN
WIGGLING WITH COLLEAGUES AND
CABINET SECRETARIES WITHOUT A
MASK INSIGHT, MEANWHILE HAD THE
AUDACITY TO SLAP FOR MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WITH A $500 FINE FOR
FAILING TO ADHERE TO HER
ANTISCIENCE MANDATE.
HERE'S THE VIDEO OF MASKS BEING
REPRIMANDED BY A STAFFER FOR THE
HOUSE SERGEANT OF ARMS DURING A
DEBATE ON THE HOUSE FLOOR
TUESDAY.
EARNED A BRONZE STAR AND A
PURPLE HEART, LOST BOTH OF HIS
LEGS IN AFGHANISTAN AS A BOMB
DISPOSAL EXPERT AND NOW THEY
WILL FIND $500 FOR NOT WEARING A
MASK, JUST UNBELIEVABLE.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION IS
NORTH CAROLINA CONGRESSMAN
MADISON CAWTHORN AND FOX NEWS
LEGAL ANALYST GREGG JARRETT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
YOU HAVE TAKEN A STRONG STANCE
AND SAID I DON'T NEED TO WEAR A
MASK ON THE FLOOR OF THE HOUSE.
WHY?
WITH THE PRINCIPAL HERE AND ARE
YOU GOING TO WIN THAT FIGHT?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF WE ARE GOING
TO WIN.
I'M SURE SHE WILL TRY TO FIND US
BUT IF SHE WANTS TO COME WITH AN
ABSOLUTELY PURE LET HER DO HER
WORST.
I BELIEVE PATRIOTIC AMERICANS
HAVE OUR BACK SO I'M WILLING TO
TAKE A STAND.
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU SAW THE
VIDEO BUT THERE IS A YOUNG
10-YEAR-OLD BOY WHO WAS
BASICALLY REPRIMANDED BECAUSE HE
WAS HAVING TO WEAR A MASK AND HE
HAS THE COURAGE TO STAND UP AND
DO WHAT THIS NATION'S LEADERS DO
NOT AND THAT MADE ME EMBOLDEN.
IMAGINE GEORGE WASHINGTON FACING
DOWN THE BRITISH OF YORKTOWN BUT
WEARING A MASK.
WE ARE NOT DESCENDED FROM
FEARFUL MEN SO IF YOU'RE ONLY
AFRAID TO WEAR A MASK BECAUSE
YOU'RE AFRAID NANCY PELOSI WILL
FIND YOU, STAND UP, BE AN
AMERICAN MAN OR WOMAN, HAVE SOME
COURAGE.
>> Jason: I THINK THERE'S AN
INTERESTING LEGAL QUESTION
BECAUSE YOU AND I WERE TALKING
EARLIER BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
HAVE THE CONSTITUTIONAL ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY OPPOSE A FINE ON
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
FIRST OF ALL, NO FEDERAL LAW
THAT EMPOWERS MASK MANDATES,
PERIOD.
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
LIMITED HEALTH AND SAFETY POWERS
BUT NOT THE FEDS AND READILY
ADMITS SHE CAN'T FORCE PEOPLE TO
GET VACCINATED, CAN'T EVEN FORCE
MEMBERS TO DISCLOSE IF THEY HAVE
BEEN VACCINATED SO SHE'S ALREADY
ON SHAKY LEGAL GROUND BUT SHE
REALLY CROSSED THE LINE WHEN SHE
BEGAN TO DOCK THE PAY OF MEMBERS
WHO REFUSED TO WEAR A MASK, SOME
OF WHICH HAVE BEEN VACCINATED
AND ARE FOLLOWING CDC
GUIDELINES.
WHY DID SHE CROSS THE LEGAL
LINE?
ARGUABLY A VIOLATION OF THE 27TH
AMENDMENT WHICH SAYS IN EFFECT
YOU CANNOT ALTER THE PAY OF
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WITHOUT
FIRST AN INTERVENING TO GENERAL
ELECTION AND THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED BUT THE POINT IS PELOSI
CAN ENACT ALL KINDS OF RULES OF
CONDUCT FOR ITS MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSE BUT THE PUNISHMENT IS
RESTRICTED TO THINGS LIKE
CENSURE AND REPRIMAND, EVEN
EXPULSION OR RESTITUTION WHICH
SHE CANNOT DO AS TRIFLE WITH THE
PAYCHECKS OF MEMBERS.
WHAT'S TO STOP HER FROM
WEAPONIZING PAYCHECKS TO FORCE A
PARTICULAR VOTE?
THAT WOULD BE EXTORTION OR
BRIBERY AND CERTAINLY GOVERNMENT
CORRUPTION.
THIS MAKES NO SENSE IN SO MANY
WAYS.
AS I MENTIONED, SO MANY PEOPLE
OF ALREADY BEEN VACCINATED, THEY
HAVE LIFTED MASK RULES OF THE
WHITE HOUSE IN THE U.S. SENATE
BUT PELOSI REFUSES TO LIFT IT IN
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
BECAUSE SHE'S ALL ABOUT EXTREME.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT SCIENCE, IT'S
ABOUT HER THIRST FOR POWER AND
CONTROL.
SHE'S ADDICTED TO TELLING PEOPLE
WHAT TO DO, HOW TO THINK, AND
HOW TO BEHAVE, NOT TO MENTION
THAT SHE'S A HYPOCRITE HAVING
BEEN CAUGHT VIOLATING MASK RULES
LOCALLY IN SAN FRANCISCO.
>> Jason: THIS IS A BIT OF
THEATER, RIGHT?
THE CAMERAS ARE FOCUSED ON THE
FLOOR OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES COME UP WITH
THIS MASK MANDATE ISN'T ENFORCED
AN OFFICE OR IN HALLS OR IN
COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
>> YOU WILL OFTEN SEE DEMOCRAT
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO ARE
WEARING NO MASKS IN THE ELEVATOR
AND AS SOON AS YOU GET TO THE
SECOND FLOOR OF THE BUILDING,
THEY DIDN'T PUT THEIR MASK ON
AND THERE WERE ABOUT TO BE ON
C-SPAN.
IT'S ALL POLITICAL THEATER AND I
THINK IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ADDICTED TO POWER.
THEY SAW HOW MUCH POWER THEY
COULD GAIN THROUGH FEAR IN OUR
DESPERATE TO KEEP HOLDING ONTO
THAT.
>> Jason: THIS IS
SENATOR MURPHY GOING TO THE
FLOOR OF THE UNITED STATES
SENATE WHERE THERE IS NOT A MASK
MANDATE BUT HE PUTS ON THE MASK
MORE THAN HE'S GOING TO VOTE AND
THEN HE TAKES IT OFF, IT'S JUST
A SHOW.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE REALLY BELIEVES
IT, BUT I THINK THERE IS A
BIGGER BROADER PRINCIPLE HERE
AND THAT IS ONE OF PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND PERSONAL
FREEDOM, CORRECT?
>> IT IS.
AND ONE OF THE GREAT MYTHS TO
EMERGE FROM THE PANDEMIC AS
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS CAN
PROHIBIT YOU FROM DOING WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION GUARANTEES YOU HAVE
A RIGHT TO DO.
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO GO TO WORK,
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO GO TO THE
LOCAL CHURCH COMING OF A RIGHT
TO SHOP FOR FOOD AND YOU HAVE A
RIGHT TO ASSEMBLE IN PLACES LIKE
OUTDOOR THEATERS AND INDOORS IN
PLACES LIKE THE HOUSE CHAMBER
WITHOUT NANCY PELOSI PUNISHING
YOU BY DOCKING YOUR PAY.
WHEN SHE IS DOING IS RANK
LAWLESSNESS.
>> Jason: I WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE LAST WORD BUT WHAT IS YOUR
TAKE ON PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY
AND THE IDEA THAT YOU GET TO
MAKE AND HAVE THE
SELF-DETERMINATION YOURSELF?
>> THOSE TWO WORDS YOU JUST USE,
SELF-DETERMINATION REALLY
EMBODIES WHAT IT TRULY MEANS TO
BE A CONSERVATIVE.
I BELIEVE WE ARE ALL ROYALTY,
YOUR HOUSE IN YOUR APARTMENT
WHERE YOU LIVE IS YOUR CASTLE,
YOU MAKE THE RULES.
WE DON'T MAKE DECREES FOR YOU IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., SO TO MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES IF YOU WANT TO WEAR A
MASK, GO AHEAD AND DO IT BUT
DON'T YOU DARE REPRIMAND ME WHEN
I DON'T HAVE ONE ON.
YOU'RE ONLY AFRAID TO WEAR A
MASK BECAUSE OF NANCY PELOSI'S
FINE WHEN WE COME BACK IN
SESSION, TAKE THE MASK OFF.
SHE'S JUST A PUPPET.
>>